months before the u.s presidential
election
amidst the coronavirus pandemic famous
rapper
kanye west says he's running for
president
in an interview he talked about the
coronavirus and said
it's all about god we need to stop doing
things that make
god mad some religious and political
leaders
say the virus is a punishment from god
a politician in pennsylvania described
the virus as
a punishment inflicted upon us for our
sins
and proposed a statewide day of
atonement
some christian evangelicals say the
virus is god's punishment for abortion
and gay marriage an israeli rabbi said
the virus is punishment for
gay pride and some islamic preachers say
the virus is punishment from allah
courtney kardashian and hulk hogan both
posted a bible verse to instagram
suggesting that the virus is god's wrath
so how popular is this idea
a 2011 survey found that about a third
of americans believe that natural
disasters are a sign from god
and that god punishes nations for its
citizens sins
according to a recent survey 11 of
americans
think the coronavirus pandemic is caused
by human sin
presumably this idea is less popular in
less religious countries like parts of
europe and australia
but in some more religious countries
they're more popular
a survey in pakistan found that almost
half
believed that a drought was god's
punishment
this idea of divine punishment comes up
whenever there's a big disaster
after hurricane katrina the haiti
earthquake indian ocean disaster the
kashmir quake
and the disaster in japan in 2011 japan
was hit
with a huge tsunami that killed
thousands of people
wiped away entire towns and caused a
nuclear meltdown
the prime minister of japan urged for
calm
the emperor spoke of hope and compassion
but
the governor of tokyo said the disaster
was punishment for the greed of the
japanese people
he used the word tenbatsu meaning divine
punishment he was widely criticized for
this statement but the next month
he was re-elected as governor so
disaster
as divine punishment is a persistent
and powerful idea what's the history of
this idea
how has it changed and how do we
understand
disaster today for thousands of years
all over the world many cultures saw
disaster
as god's punishment in ancient china
rulers were believed to have a mandate
from heaven
disasters were heaven's punishment or
warning
meaning the ruler could lose their
throne because they've failed or been
sinful according to legend in the reign
of king
tang there were terrible droughts so
tang asked if too much
luxury or corruption or women caused the
disaster
he offered himself as a sacrifice in
repentance
but the heavens showed mercy and the
reigns came in vanuatu
volcanic eruptions were believed to come
from demons or spirits
punishing people for breaking cultural
rules
in islamic scripture disasters are often
signs of the apocalypse
or divine punishments there's a story in
the quran
about a prophet who gives a town a
miraculous camel
the town's people hurt the camel so
allah destroys the town with an
earthquake
in northern europe floods and frosts
were seen as god's punishment
there's a german legend of a town called
rongholt
the townspeople were immoral and the
priest got drunk so
god swept the town into the sea in a
great storm
some people called roonholt the atlantis
of the north sea
in mesoamerica people believed that
droughts and plagues were divine
punishment
so they offered human sacrifice the
aztecs sent
victims to the gods to plead mercy for
our sins
according to a mayan manuscript one
sacrifice victim
took upon herself the guilt of the
locusts that destroyed their crops
before her heart was cut out
in the bible god sends lots of disasters
as punishments he destroys the sinful
cities of sodom and gomorrah with a
reign of burning sulphur
god sends ten plagues to egypt turning
the river nile to blood sending locusts
and frogs and a storm of
hail and fire and there's the story of
the flood
where god wipes out humanity for our
wickedness
the biblical flood story is predated by
similar mesopotamian flood myths
like in the epic of gilgamesh the
ancient greeks had the flood myth of
deucalion
where zeus sends a flood to wipe out
sinful humanity
so for a very long time all over the
world
many people saw disaster as god's
punishment
and it's easy to imagine why when
something terrible happens we want to
understand
why it happened we want to believe that
there's meaning
to our suffering divine punishment
gives a reason for disaster and it can
give us a feeling of control
like yes the disaster is terrible but we
can avoid future disasters by repenting
or making sacrifice or
blaming the gays and [ __ ] like when the
earth is shaking and the seas crash onto
land it sure seems like the big man's
pissed
so for thousands of years religious
explanations were the best explanations
we had
but eventually things changed
the enlightenment was a time in 18th
century europe that sparked new ideas in
science and philosophy
people like voltaire descartes isaac
newton
challenged the old ideas of the church
and state
one of these old ideas was philosophical
optimism
the belief that the world that exists is
the best possible world
and everything that happens is just and
necessary
in god's plan alexander pope said
whatever
is is right but this belief was
shaken in the lisbon earthquake of 1755.
the time lisbon was one of the biggest
richest and most famous cities in europe
but on the morning of a religious
holiday when the churches were packed
with worshippers
lisbon was hit by a huge earthquake and
tsunami
churches came crashing down on the
worshippers and the harbour was washed
away
fissures tore the city apart and fires
burned for days
tens of thousands of people were killed
and almost all the city was destroyed
one of the only parts that survived were
the brothels
in the red light district the priests
declared that the quake was
god's judgment in this painting this
angel with a fiery sword symbolizes
divine retribution
a prominent priest in lisbon wrote what
a great harvest of sinful
souls such disasters send to hell
and urged the people to repent but
enlightenment thinkers questioned the
church they asked
awkward questions like why would god
destroy the royal palace
but leave the brothels standing what
sin was god punishing that was worth
killing thousands
of people when lisbon was a devout city
celebrating a religious holiday
enlightenment thinkers passionately
debated how to fit this disaster with
their faith
voltaire wrote a poem about the quake
attacking the ideas of optimism and
divine punishment
he asked what crime what sin had these
young hearts conceived that lie
bleeding and torn on mother's breast did
fallen lisbon deeper drink of vice than
london paris or madrid does this
hellish gulf in portugal really make the
world better
couldn't god have just [ __ ] not made
volcanoes and earthquakes another
enlightenment thinker called rosso
replied to voltaire he tried to defend
the idea of optimism but also said the
disaster was partly humanity's fault
because lisbon's buildings were too tall
and too close together and that made the
earthquake dangerous
the prime minister of lisbon rebuilt the
city with some of the world's first
earthquake-resistant buildings and he
sent a questionnaire about the quake all
over portugal which was one of the first
ever systematic studies of the effects
of a disaster
immanuel kant tried to explain the quake
with science theorizing that it was
caused by
underground gases and minerals the
lisbon quake
dramatically changed how people think
about disaster
new ideas in seismology disaster
management urban planning
spread across europe and the world and
they worked
today in tokyo 250 years
later and 11 000 kilometers from lisbon
the city of tokyo has mastered
earthquake mitigation
there's training and drills and
instructions there are earthquake
simulation machines to train school kids
earthquake resistant technology and
regulations make buildings safer and
there's a warning system to send alerts
modern technology and governance can
make disasters
much less dangerous and scary instead of
terrifying inexplicable calamities they
can be
natural phenomena that we can manage and
control
psychology research shows that we're
more likely to believe in god
and to see meaning in randomness when
we're feeling anxious
and like we're not in control so when
disaster is managed and controlled we
might not need religious explanations
like divine punishment
today when things do go wrong we tend
not to blame god or sin
instead we blame the government
according to surveys most americans
blame local or foreign governments for
the coronavirus
most americans disapprove of the
government's response to the pandemic
there are also protests against
government lockdown measures
there's criticism of bodies like the
world health organization the un
and eu so when disaster strikes
instead of turning to god the higher
power we turn to
is government some people believe
conspiracy theories
according to surveys more than a quarter
of americans think
bill gates wants to use corona vaccines
to track
people 12 percent of australians think
that 5g
is spreading the virus and 39 think the
virus was
created in a chinese lab so instead of
believing that the disaster
is god's plan people believe it's
china's plan
or bill gates's plan according to
psychologists people believe in
conspiracy theories
for similar reasons that people believe
in religion
it's a coping strategy that helps you
deal with a stressful
uncertain world because it's terrifying
to see that the world is a mess
no one's really in charge and it's hard
to tell who's good and who's bad
so it's actually reassuring to believe
that all the evil in the world
comes from the illuminati or whoever and
everything's part of their evil plan
but you are the heroic woke resistance
and
anyone who says otherwise is just part
of the conspiracy
a conspiracy theory can make you part of
a fun cool group who believe
the same thing like a religion but in a
religion
the higher power is god while in
conspiracy theories
the ones in control who cause the
disaster
are humans in the last hundred years
some of the worst disasters aren't
natural disasters like earthquakes
they're man-made disasters like nuclear
meltdowns oil spills
industrial accidents and climate change
our emissions are warming the earth
melting the arctic
bleaching the reefs worsening extreme
weather events and fires
whenever there's a hurricane or a
heatwave now instead of blaming god or
sin
people attribute it to man-made climate
change
poverty and famine is increasingly seen
as a man-made
problem caused by human conflict and
mismanagement
war terrorism nuclear weapons as human
power increases
so does our capacity for destruction and
disaster
so we increasingly fear not apocalypse
from god
but apocalypse from ourselves
in ancient mythology apocalypse comes
from the gods
the norse ragnarok the biblical
armageddon the epic of gilgamesh
and these kinds of stories are still
popular today
like superhero movies about godlike
beings fighting against magical
apocalypse
but in many modern myths apocalypse is
caused by
humans and human technology man-made
robots in terminator and the matrix
man-made climate change in the day after
tomorrow
nuclear war in fallout pop culture
reveals this fear that we will destroy
ourselves and a great symbol of this is
the zombie apocalypse
the zombie apocalypse isn't always
caused by
humans but it's a disaster made of
humans
a zombie horde looks a lot like the
apocalyptic floods of
myth a vast terrifying unstoppable
all-consuming force but the biblical
flood from
god is made of water a natural
force while the zombie horde is made of
people if you watch some of the original
zombie movies like dawn of the dead
it's not just about spooky bitey walking
dead men
it's about the failure of human
institutions like government and media
it's about mindless consumer culture
greed and tribalism
inequality and division all the evil
that's brought out in a crisis
you can see zombies as an embodiment of
all the worst parts of human nature
the evil that we fear we will find in
ourselves
when disaster strikes the word
apocalypse
means revelation and we hope the
disaster will reveal the good in us
but we fear it will reveal the worst
that we can't blame god or sin or 5g
that there is no plan punishment or
conspiracy
we fear that the disaster is
us disaster experts say
that on its own an earthquake or tsunami
or virus
is not a disaster because these things
only do
damage if we leave ourselves vulnerable
to them
by failing to properly prepare and
respond
it's been 250 years since lesbian
we know that earthquakes and tsunamis
and viruses happen
we have the science and research and
resources
experts have warned us for decades to
prepare for a pandemic
urging for evidence-based policy and
public health measures
prevention and precautions it's not
sexy it wouldn't make a good movie
there's no
good versus evil there's no lone
hero like noah or jacqueline or brad
pitt
to save us from apocalypse our myths
mislead us sometimes saving millions of
lives doesn't require
individual heroism or repentance or
sacrifice
it requires careful planning cooperation
organization rationality compassion
on a local political and international
level that's what separates us from
zombies maybe the deadliest
and most contagious viruses are the
myths we tell ourselves about apocalypse
stories and ideas define our history
their ancients built empires on religion
and myth
the enlightenment spread science and
philosophy
now we've got kanye marvel trump and
whoever the [ __ ] started the 5g stuff
every day mutant strains of information
go
viral online they infect our brains and
change us rallying us into factions and
mass
movements shifting world economies and
polities
every choice we make is based on what we
think we know so what we believe
might be the difference between
enlightenment
and apocalypse after the disaster in
japan
sato hiru wrote that today when the
extinction of humanity
is increasingly becoming possible we are
all
individually required as bearers of the
future
to make the tough choice of which path
to follow we are facing a historical
turning point and we need to think hard
about which direction to take
thanks for watching if you want more
videos like this
please let us know in the comments and
consider supporting on patreon
this video took a lot of research and
work
and it's not sponsored so we're relying
on your support
for a few bucks a month you can get
videos early and you can vote on our
next song of ice and fire video topic
sign up at the link below thanks to
patrons alexandra eliades andreas barde
brittany
hearn braden lee hall hoyland tam and
panda fire cheers